Je fume du crack depuis que j'ai 15 ans.
Je fume des joints, je bois de l'alcool,
je prends du Valium...
Je fais n'importe quoi.
Je vole, je fais la manche,
je me prostitue au rond-point
d'Aubervilliers tous les soirs.
Si t'es du côté d’Aubervilliers, si t'as 50 balles,
eh ben on baise et on se voit, voilà.
C’est tout, y’a pas de longue histoire.
Oh, désolée hein, mais à un moment il faut être clair.
Vous avez été nombreux à réagir
à notre documentaire sur la colline du crack,
ce lieu au nord de Paris
où dealers et consommateurs de crack
se donnent rendez-vous
depuis une dizaine d’années.
Aujourd’hui, la colline et le camps
ont été complètement évacués.
Pour Brut, j’avais rencontré Laurie,
cette jeune belge de 19 ans, enceinte,
qui a commencé le crack très jeune.
Vous avez été beaucoup
à être touchés par son histoire.
Quitter ici, c’est trop dur.
Je suis toxicomane depuis 4 ans.
Depuis que j’ai 15 ans, j’en ai 19.
Tu te rends compte, Camille ?
Tu te rends compte ?
Je suis restée en contact avec Laurie
et depuis ce tournage,
beaucoup de choses ont changé dans sa vie.
Je suis en Belgique chez ma maman.
La vidéo ça m’a permis de voir, t’as vu,
que j’étais arrivée à un point où je ne pouvais
presque plus faire marche arrière.
Laurie a accepté de nous raconter
la suite de son histoire,
mais aussi son passé très difficile.
Avec elle, on va essayer de vous montrer
comment on peut partir de la colline du crack,
se reconstruire,
même si, évidemment, tout reste fragile.
Maman, eh, je suis plus grande que toi bientôt.
Et t’as des talons.
Mais je vais plus grandir, moi,
je suis enceinte.
T’as mal aux pieds ?
Non, je marche toujours bizarrement, moi.
Mais enfin !
Quel bébé !
Je suis en Belgique
chez ma maman,
parce que j’attends un bébé.
Et je ne veux plus retourner à Paris, hein,
c’est fini.
Oh je te jure.
Sinon j’allais finir comme les autres, hein.
Ah, je ne voulais pas.
Je me suis vue comme ça,
comme une clocharde,
et ça m’a fait bizarre.
J’ai vu tous les commentaires des gens,
et tout ça, ça m’a fait bizarre.
Le reportage m’a vraiment
émue fortement.
Je ne pensais pas, en fait,
qu’elle reviendrait à la maison
et qu’elle serait calme comme ça,
que je pourrais avoir un dialogue
de femmes entre femmes.
Je pensais qu'elle serait encore
trop dans ses désillusions et…
et dans...
Je ne sais pas, il y a une atmosphère à Paris
qui se fait entre eux et c’est vraiment…
...un monde parallèle.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas trop difficile
pour une femme enceinte de vivre ici ?
C’est l’horreur.
Y'a des mecs qui veulent te baiser
malgré que tu es enceinte.
Bon, je le fais quand même.
Que mes parents m'en veulent pas
s'ils me voient,
parce que je leur ai dit
que j’avais arrêté de fumer.
Le crack, c’est bon.
À la première taffe, c’est super bon.
C’est le truc le plus bon dans ta vie.
Et puis après, ensuite, tu te dis :
“Mais putain, mais j’ai fait de la merde !
Pourquoi j’ai fait ça ?”
Mais c’est trop tard, tu es déjà dedans.
Tu vois ?
Et puis, après, il te faut quelques années
pour te remettre mentalement de ça.
Je vais m'enfuir, moi.
Un jour, je vais partir en courant.
J’y arriverai pas…
C'est dur.
C’est trop dur.
Quitter ici, c’est trop dur.
Ma mère, elle me manque.
Et pourquoi tu ne retournes
pas la voir ?
Parce que je suis dans le crack.
Chaque fois, c’est toujours demain, demain.
Comme une conne j'étais à la colline
le jour de Noël aussi.
Toujours à la colline...
Je t'aime.
Y’a des années que je suis
sous somnifère pour dormir,
parce que sinon je ne dormais pas.
Toute la nuit je regardais mon plafond
et je me disais :
“Qu’est-ce qu’elle fait ? Où elle est ?
Il fait dégueulasse dehors,
est-ce qu’elle n’a pas froid ?
Est-ce qu’elle a un toit pour dormir ?"
Et quand je n’avais pas de nouvelles
pendant deux ou trois jours, je me disais
“ça y est, elle est séquestrée quelque part”.
Je pensais à des trucs horribles donc...
c’était vraiment affreux.
Ça va ?
Ça, c’est pour le tissage.
Ça veut dire que je dois te tresser
les cheveux en rondelle,
et puis je te couds ça.
Oh ! Je veux !
Tu sais, Laurie, pour moi, c’est un petit bébé.
Donc on doit en prendre soin.
Elle a de la chance, elle a une maman
qui est gentille quand même.
J’ai parlé avec elle, sa mère.
Elle m’a dit de faire attention à elle.
J’ai des grandes photos d’elle,
des superbes photos d’elle.
Mais…
C’est comme beaucoup de souvenirs,
on les met sur le côté et puis…
Là, elle était déguisée en Claudette
pour la fête de l’école.
Ah ouais... super...
Une petite Claudette.
Ça c'est quand les dents ont
commencé à se développer !
Non maman, t'es sérieuse là ?
Oh t’es mignonne là.
Et elle était comment Laurie,
quand elle était petite fille ?
Bah, c’était une chouette petite fille,
très inventive.
J’étais grosse, même là.
Elle avait énormément d’imagination.
Voilà, là elle apprend
à fumer avec un cure-dents.
Ah, c’est celle-là.
Oui, ça c’est toi.
Regarde.
Ça c’est mon père.
On le voit un petit peu, juste.
Et ça c’était moi.
T’as vu, là, déjà, j’étais dans une tente.
Ça c’est mes dessins.
Ça représente quoi ?
C’est le corps d’une femme.
Alors voilà. Mon histoire est assez
longue, triste et barbante.
Mon père, pendant un week-end sur deux,
me tripotait de mes deux ans à mes six ans et demi.
De mes six ans et demi
à mes sept ans et demi c’était du viol.
Maman a porté plainte avec moi,
classé sans succès…
Classé sans suite.
J’étais perdue.
Vers trois ans et demi, elle allait le mercredi
après-midi et un week-end sur deux
chez son papa.
Et quand elle est rentrée, elle se
réfugiait sous la table
et elle ne voulait pas nous parler.
En ayant très peur d’aller à la douche,
parce que son papa lui avait fait mal au sexe.
C’est ce qu’elle m’a dit avec ses mots d’enfant.
Ça s’est reproduit,
donc j’ai été déposer plainte
et j’ai été à l’hôpital Tivoli, à la Louvière.
Et là, ils ne croyaient pas trop
au comportement incestueux du papa.
C’était là que tout avait déjà commencé.
Sans le savoir, ma vie, du haut de mes sept ans,
venait déjà de prendre une autre tournure.
J’ai carrément fait descendre une enquête,
enfin, j’ai ouvert une enquête mais…
qui a été mal…
mal dirigée, bâclée.
Et les faits ont été classés sans suite.
Donc Laurie a toujours eu cette...
cette vengeance, cette hargne, parce que...
voilà… on avait cette impression
qu’elle avait menti,
alors qu’elle ne mentait pas.
Un enfant de trois ans et demi
ne ment pas pour des choses comme ça.
Quand j’ai rencontré le papa de mon fils,
on a pris un certain espace
avec le père de ma fille.
Et, à partir de ce moment-là,
avec le papa de mon fils,
on a décidé de la mettre dans un internat
où elle serait vraiment hors contexte
de la maison et où elle serait loin
de son papa, entre guillemets.
Où il ne pourrait pas, entre guillemets,
la retrouver.
Pour moi, ça a été la plus mauvaise idée,
c’est de la mettre en internat.
Parce que de l’internat, après,
ça a chuté vers les centres psychiatriques.
Parce que, comme elle ne s’adaptait pas
avec les autres enfants en internat,
ils ont dit qu’elle avait
un problème psychiatrique.
Ils m’ont placée six ans en centre
pédopsychiatrique car j’avais du mal.
Maman avait un nouvel homme,
un nouveau bébé, une nouvelle maison.
À 12 ans, je me scarifiais chaque jour
et je commençais à fumer des clopes,
seulement des paquets Camel
que je crapotais à moitié.
Après, à 13 ans, fugues, traîner
et dormir avec des punks à chien anarchistes
qui m’ont emmenée et fait goûter
le fameux crack,
à la fameuse Porte de la Chapelle.
Moi quand je fume, parfois
je peux voir ma grand-mère.
Elle me supplie de ne pas aller
vers la lumière d’où elle vient.
Et elle me répète sans cesse qu’il est tôt.
Elle s’évanouit comme dans un rêve.
Est-ce possible ou est-ce le crack
qui me met dans ces illusions ?
C’est mon journal intime.
Ici, c’est un peu galère de garder ça, en fait.
Force et honneur.
Par exemple, ça, c’est mes dessins.
Tu vois bien ?
Tu sais, il n’y a pas que du sale ici.
Y’a aussi des gens qui souffrent.
Des artistes inconnus, des artistes…
qui cherchent juste à…
Des gens juste perdus, je crois,
qui cherchent juste à être retrouvés.
Y’a des histoires, y’a des poèmes,
y’a des chansons.
Oh celui-là maman, j’adore !
Ce dessin-là maman !
Laurie, je t’ai déjà dit,
je n’ai jamais rien jeté de tes affaires, moi.
J’ai eu quelques fois droit à des dessins
assez gores aussi.
Parfois, elle me faisait peur avec ses dessins.
C’était ton écriture, ça.
Regarde.
C’est toi qui as écrit ça.
C’était il y a longtemps !
Le vent souffle, il fait noir,
il pleut, j’ai froid.
Je suis recherchée, je fais donc
attention aux voitures qui passent.
Je suis remplie d’humeurs différentes,
en passant par la peur,
la poussée d’adrénaline, le stress.
Je reprend donc une bouffée sur mon doseur,
pipe à crack,
et tout redevient comme avant,
complètement défoncée.
Je fais le vide en moi, littéralement.
Ce soir, un client m’attend à Porte de la Chapelle,
sur le périphérique, à la pompe à essence...
Laurie, elle a toujours tout écrit
de ce qui se passait dans sa vie,
de ses jours et ses nuits
de jeune toxicomane.
Et elle a aussi, parfois, filmé.
Je me rends à la pompe.
Je vois mon client et il me lance :
“10 euros une pipe, ça marche ?”
“Non, 20 euros tout compris, OK ?”
“OK.”
Je monte dans sa Porsche.
Il met la radio.
Cet homme doit avoir, à peu près, 30/35 ans.
Cheveux grisonnants, balafré,
ce mec me fait peur.
C’est mon client, je le connais,
il est réglo.
Ici, les meufs en manque de crack
demandent 5 euros.
Moi, toujours minimum 20 euros.
Personne en vue, je me déshabille,
il met sa capote.
“Eh, tu aimes quoi niveau sexe ?”
La question était gênante.
Je lui ai répondu vaguement :
“Oh, un peu de tout.
Je fais tout moi. Dès que la capote
est pleine, ça fait 20 euros.”
Mes trois premiers mois dans le crack.
C’est chaud, hein maman ?
Je ne savais pas que c’était autant…
C’est hard ce que j’écrivais, maman.
Je ne me suis jamais permis
de lire tes trucs.
Quand je voyais que c’était tes écritures,
je mettais dans une farde...
Ça fait quelque chose, oui…
Bah au moins, t’as vu,
je suis réelle quand j’écris.
J’écris tout ce que je pense,
tout ce que je vois.
Et quand est-ce que vous avez su,
Laurence, la première fois
qu'elle a pris du crack, vous vous êtes
dit quoi et vous l'avez su comment ?
Je ne lui ai pas dit.
Pris du crack, j’étais pas au courant.
Mais après, je vois qu’elle traînait
avec des gens qui ne faisaient que ça donc...
Voilà.
Et on ne sait pas mettre sa main devant.
C’est trop tard.
C’est comme les fugues,
on ne sait pas mettre sa main devant.
On peut pas l’attacher au radiateur
de la maison et dire :
“Voilà, maintenant, tu vas plus fuguer.
Maintenant, tu ne vas plus prendre ça.
Maintenant, tu ne vas plus faire ça."
Parce qu’un enfant, plus on va lui interdire
et plus il aura envie d’aller
contre l’avis de ses parents.
Parce que c’est contradictoire, un enfant.
Il est temps qu’on vienne la chercher, hein.
Et qu’on la sauve de là.
Franchement.
Elle a eu, au moins,  le temps de pouvoir
apprendre beaucoup de choses.
Il faut qu’elle apprenne encore, la pauvre.
Je ne veux pas qu’elle souffre.
Ça me fait tellement mal au cœur.
Elle a fait sa propre expérience
et, franchement, moi-même j’aurais
pas été capable de faire
tout ce qu’elle a fait,
de traverser tout ce qu’elle a traversé.
Moi, ce qui me faisait le plus peur,
c’est qu’un jour les pompiers m’appellent
et me disent qu’ils avaient trouvé ma fille…
sans vie.
Ça, c’était un truc…
Ça me faisait hyper peur.
Tu ne vas pas pleurer, maman ?
Je vais pas mourir, maman.
Je peux pas mourir moi,
je suis “immourable”.
Et toi Laurie, tu te rendais compte ou pas
que ta mère était inquiète comme ça ?
Non, je ne me rendais pas compte
que ma maman souffrait.
Mais je voulais à un moment donné
la faire souffrir.
Parce que j'avais souffert moi-même.
Mais Aliou ! Réveille-toi, ouais !
Mais Aliou, regarde,
c'est tes cadeaux wesh !
J'ai chopé des vêtements sur le périph',
la vie de ma race je les ai volés.
Regarde !
C'est tout neuf !
On dit merci, hein connard !
Fais-moi un bisou.
Aliou, il me manque.
Rien à faire.
J’ai besoin de lui.
Sinon je ne vais pas aller bien.
Ça me fait peur parce que je sais qu’elle est
encore en contact avec des gens de Paris...
Elle est retournée plusieurs fois à Paris
parce que, justement, elle n’avait pas
coupé les contacts avec des gens
qu’elle côtoyait là-bas.
Je leur parle, tu vois,
parce que c’est les seules personnes
avec qui j’ai parlé pendant quatre ans.
Donc, du coup, c’est normal quoi,
tu vois, moi je n’arrive pas à me remettre
tout de suite dans la vie réelle.
Tu vois, il faut un passage comme ça.
Un passage où je parle avec eux et voilà.
Et t’as pas envie de te faire des nouveaux
copains en Belgique ?
Non.
Tu peux nous montrer les dessins que tu fais
en ce moment, depuis que tu es rentrée ?
Ouais, c’est des dessins pour mettre
dans la chambre de mon bébé.
C’est des bébés Minnie et Mickey.
Et ça fait combien de temps
maintenant que tu ne fumes plus ?
Bah là ça fait un peu plus d’une semaine.
Mais ça va, je gère.
Franchement, j’ai plus envie de fumer.
En fait, quand dans ta tête t’as plus envie
de fumer de crack,
eh ben, le crack il s’enlève
tout seul de ta tête.
Si, évidemment, t’es tout le temps
“crack, crack, crack, crack, crack”,
tu te dis “je suis en manque”,
ça c'est le truc qu'il ne faut pas te dire.
Maman, tu veux bien me coiffer ?
Prends des élastiques sous
l'évier de la salle de bains.
Laurie, si c'était à refaire, est-ce que
tu referais pareil ou pas ?
Si jamais j’avais pas vécu tout ce que
j’ai vécu, je crois que j’aurais pas pris
conscience que je suis bien à la maison.
Tu vois, après avoir fait le tour du monde,
tout ce qu’on veut c’est être à la maison, non ?
Tu vois...
C'est ça...
Maman...?
Oui ?
Tu me fais mal à mes petits cheveux, là.